Okay, ladies and gents, probably the most exciting part of this little mini
course is
breaking down some trades.
Trades that have been actually executed by myself and the members, trades that
are in
alignment with the system that I trade or one of the systems I trade, I have
multiple
different trading strategies and the thing is with trading strategies, you have
, right,
it's not as black and white as just, you know, have a strategy and follow that
strategy
all times.
It's not how trading works.
There are certain market environments.
There are certain market conditions that some strategies perform better than
others.
And so I have, you know, three main trading strategies.
And then within those trading strategies, I have over 10 different setup
variations.
Let that sink in for a minute.
So it sounds complicated.
It's actually not that complicated, but, you know, each of them are slightly
different.
And the reason this is important is because there are different market
environments.
You have trending environments.
You have range bound environments.
You have to understand price.
You have to understand context and then you will understand which strategy to
execute and
which strategy to, you know, kind of hold back on or certain things like that.
Again, all of which is well documented inside of the school.
So the trades that I'm going to be sharing with you are trades taken with
members and
they are trades following kind of my A plus set up for my SMC strategy.
That's what I would call it.
So they're all part of the three trades and they are part of the same strategy,
but they
are actually slightly different setups and they are actually very high
probability setups.
So these trades are A plus setups.
Now, they don't happen the most frequently.
I'll be talking to you.
They're not trades you'll find every day.
But when you see them, you will know that you are in a really good area and got
a really
good redone price.
So we'll kick things off.
I've kind of already broken down a little bit, but I'm going to title full
circle.
So there's two trades on the fourth of Feb.
It was actually another trade that I took on the morning of the fourth of
February that
I didn't actually I'm not going to break down because they're part of a
different trading
strategy.
Again, likewise, this is really unfortunate.
There was also a couple of different trades taken on these days that again, I'm
not going
to break down.
But anyway, we had a crazy day on the third of February.
We took two trades, live trading, by the way, everything is live documented on
a call with
our live trading students.
We took two trades, one in London, I'm one in New York session, and both of
them, when
I tell you that like it was just crazy, both of them came four pips away from
hitting the
full target.
It would have been a 15% day and became four pips away and we hit break even on
both trades.
But yeah, then there was a luckily there was a trade on the fourth of Feb in
London session
that hits a profit, and then there was another two trades in the New York
session.
So ended up being a really good starts Feb anyway.
The trades I'm going to recognize you are two short positions taken in New York
session
and they are scaling trades.
They are high probability trades.
So the first thing that I want to do and emphasize is the directional bias.
So right now it says no clear read, but here's the context, right?
So you by now you understand the daily bias.
You can see then that we have a very aggressive push up followed by the seller,
right?
The rebalancing of price.
When price gets too far over extended, it wants to come back and rebalance back
into
its comfort zone, let's just say.
So you can see then by looking to the daily bias, we have close below, right,
open manipulation
close below.
So the daily bias here is bearish.
Now notice that we close below and then we have an inside bar, which is an
indecisive
level of price.
But based on your understanding of the overall price and targets and things of
that nature,
you can kind of understand where price will go.
So on this day, my read on price is very clearly bearish.
I'm expecting price to trade into these lows down here.
Now what you're seeing is we've opened price and we've wicked above the
previous days
high and now we're trading bearish.
A lot of the times when you see price wick below or above the previous days
high or low
and then start trading the opposite direction, you know it's going to be a
reversal.
I can show you many different occasions, like here's a perfect example, right?
Bearish candle, we wick below the previous days low, right, we open here, we
start trading
bearish, we wick below the previous days low and then we start trading bullish
and then
we trade above the high and then the next day we open, sell off and expand,
right?
I can show you so many different examples of this.
Here we're bullish, we wick above the previous days high, we start trading bear
ish, it's
a very good sign that we're going to be reversing and then we get a very
aggressive reversal.
So again, this is something that I can show you time and time again.
We wick below the previous days low, we close in here, then we open, we trade
higher first
and then we start trading lower, we wick above that previous days high and then
when that
starts shifting bearish, we know that we get in the sell off and so I can show
you this
time and time and time again.
I've already kind of emphasized the data as well behind this.
So we wick above that high, we start selling off, but we have an even higher
confidence
and that is we have this weekend opening gap.
So from the Friday to the Monday, notice this is Friday, this is Monday, market
closes here
on the Friday and opens up here on the Monday.
So there's a huge gap in here that we then trade through and upon trading
through it,
we also leave a bearish for a value gap.
So we have an overlapping market in efficiency, which we're now trading back
into and away
from.
So this is super high probability that we're going to get bearish price action.
Right, that's just the daily bias, that's the directional bias.
We're super expecting lower prices.
Now, that's also why I was able to take the shorts in here before we actually
confirmed
bearish.
Now we look at market structure.
So not only do we have a bearish daily read on price, we also have a bearish M
15 structure.
And again, we don't need to guess which the highs are, which the lows are,
because the
indicator does that for you.
So we can clearly see that we are bearish, we can see the swing highs here, we
've had
a change of character here.
So we were actually bullish.
We were bearish, then we were bullish, then bearish, and then bullish and now
bearish.
So now we bearish and we already expect that these lows are going to go, right?
So we're bearish and we're expecting that these lows are going to go.
So this is my London sweep Asia, New York continuation model.
And essentially what happens is London sweeps Asia and gives an aggressive move
, gives some
type of break of structure or change of character.
And then we're expecting New York to have a retracement into the area of
interest, right?
So the supply zone that was formed in London before having a sell off.
That is what it is.
And also, if you know anything about Wyckoff, this is a very nice Wyckoff phase
two type
two distribution schematic, where we have the up thrust after distribution.
So we're going to mark the distribution that is also the supply range in here.
And it's basically this buy to sell range.
That's our point of interest.
So it's very simple.
When New York is opening, we're waiting for a retracement into here and then
confirmation
and then we're going to enter.
And it's step by step.
First of all, you get your directional bias.
Second of all, you get your market structure bias.
Third, you get your point of interest that can be a supply zone.
It could be an area of liquidity that price is going to reverse from.
Then you need your confirmation, then you need your risk management.
That's it.
It's step by step.
So now we have a clear directional bias.
We have clear market structure and we have a clear point of interest.
So we've had our three steps.
Now step four is a reversal into that level and confirmation.
So it's either we reverse into it or we don't.
And you can see here we actually do reverse into the level, right?
So we play that.
So when you hit this level, now it's about confirmation and confirmation is one
minute
market structure.
And you can see here, again, you don't have to do the heavy lift and indicate
all of this
for you.
You can see that the one minute timeframe is bullish right now.
You can see how to change a character.
So it's bullish.
Therefore, we are need to wait for it to shift bearish.
So right now when I'm looking at this, price has to go all the way down here
and then back
here and then down here.
It's not going to happen.
So the only way that we can get into the market and I know this ahead of time
is if
we get a manipulation and then a shift.
And again, if you know about Wyckoff and Wyckoff schematics, you will
understand that this is
also if we do shift here and shift here, that is a Wyckoff phase two
distribution schematic.
So we have a 15 minute Wyckoff and then a one minute Wyckoff inside of the 15
minute
Wyckoff level.
Just know when you have all of these confluences, it's like just clear and
obvious.
So what do we have?
Really aggressive manipulation and heavy follow through.
Now on top of all of everything, I'll just give you all the confidence.
Well, it's an A plus set up for me, how I grade an A plus set up is imagine a
set of
scales, right?
And on one hand, you have reasons that price would trade higher.
And the other hand, the reasons of price would trade lower.
If you're bearish and you're looking for shorts, if your scale for price
trading lower is
so much heavier than your price for trading higher, that is how you know you
have a high
probably set up.
If everything you understand, directional bias, market structure, lower time
frame market
structure, distribution schematics, right, lower time frame, order flow, if all
of these
things are stacked in your favor.
And there's nothing really that tells you that price going to trade against it.
That's when you know you have a high probability set up.
And so that is step number four, which is confirmation.
We have a clear directional bias.
We have a clear M15 bias.
We have a clear point of interest.
Now we have the clear confirmation because now the one minute timeframe is bear
ish and
the one minute timeframe tells us this is price now.
So our daily and our 15 minute give us an idea of what the day is going to do.
Our one minute gives us an idea of what's happening right now.
And since we want to understand and be involved in everything, we want to
understand what's
happening today, right, intraday.
And then one thing known what's going to happen.
The other thing is timing what's going to happen and the one minute is all
about time
because the one minute is about the now.
And so you're combining what's going to happen today with what's happening now.
And when they go a line, that is your trigger because understanding what's
going to happen
today, but then ignoring what's happening right now will get you in a lot of
trouble.
And I think that's something that a lot of people get messed up on.
If you're the type of trader that is able to read price and consistently able
to understand
where price is going to go, but you just struggle getting into the market or
every time you
try to get in, you get stop loss, stop loss, stop loss.
And then you can't get in and then price goes to your direction.
You need help with understanding where and when, when being key and where being
key.
You already know what, you know what's going to happen.
You just don't know when it's going to happen and where it's going to happen
from.
Everything is what, when and where.
So we know the what, we know the where, and now we know the when.
And so now we need to find our entry and it's going to be the same thing, right
?
Same principles.
This very nice looking gap is inefficient.
It's probably going to get rebalanced, plain and simple.
And again, for me, what I'm looking for is a five wrist reward, right?
Five R is really what I want to get.
Five R is the minimum that I want to take.
And so that becomes the trade.
And so now it's a case of getting tagged in, right?
This is the actual swing low.
This is the actual M 15 swing low, but that is only if three are.
And because I understand that price is probably going to trade lower anyway
based off of everything
that I can see, I can now afford to risk by moving my, take profits to five R.
Now this is where people get, this is where people get in trouble because many
people
see this, right?
Price comes right near their entry point and then they don't get tagged.
They don't get tagged.
And then price starts selling.
And what do they do, they chase the market and then they start putting their
orders in
here, right?
They're entry down here and their stop loss up here and then they get stopped
out, right?
Or they cancel their order and think they've missed out on the move.
You have to be patient.
You might stop loss here.
Okay.
I'm going to get myself in.
Now we've had a little bit of a breakdown here, not a break of structure, by
the way, just
a little break.
And now I get in and then I get stop loss.
And then price starts selling.
Okay, I'm going to get back in order block here, stop loss is going to go in
here.
Okay, good, good, everything is great.
And then stop loss and all you have to do is be patient.
I see so many traders suffer with that level of impatience or you're the type
of trader
that does the reverse and you're more conservative and you get in here and
price is chopping around
here and you have an aggressive move up here and I'm just going to close the
trade because
you can't handle the fact that it's coming closest to stop loss and in your
head, you're
like, it's going to hit stop loss anyway, so I'll just close the trade, right?
And then you close the trade and price starts selling off.
And these types of things, these are technical, these are psychological, which
is why you
have to have an inner edge as well as an outer edge.
Your indicator is part of your outer edge.
These models that I'm showing you in your trading strategy, that's part of your
outer
edge.
If you don't have the correct inner edge, then yeah, you will struggle to stick
to your
plan.
Having a plan is one thing, but following it is a complete another one.
So yeah, again, another micro distribution schematic.
Notice they all follow the same suit.
You have a run up in price, a slow down, a manipulation and a sell off, right?
A run up in price, a slow down, a manipulation and a sell off.
Notice that pattern and pay very close attention to it, that is wipe off
distribution.
And so again, all of these are given extra confirmation.
So now what I see, especially when we break this low, now we break this low.
Now I know that I'm in a very good position.
I'm like, on the low edge, I'm going to take a look at this, and I'm going to
take a look
at this, and I'm going to take a look at this, I'm going to take a look at this
, I'm going
to take a look at this, I'm going to take a look at this, I'm going to take a
look at
this on the money, I'm in the right trade.
The market is shown me itself.
These setups don't present themselves every day.
And so when they do a lot of the time, people make mistakes because they don't
double down.
They're afraid to back themselves, they're afraid to bet on these high
probability trades.
But when you're right, you need to be doubling down.
When you're on the money, you need to be doubling down.
This is why people leave a lot of money on the table, is because when the
market's moving
in your direction and everything is just clean and a plus, that's your time to
double down.
But most people are conservative.
Most people have the issue, again, psychological issue, of when things are
going against them,
they want to double down.
When they take a loss and then two losses, that's when they want to double down
because
they want to revenge trade, they want to make their money back.
And then when the opposite happens, when trades are running in your favor and
prices running
down, they don't want to double down because they don't like the idea of price
coming back.
And they see they're in profit right now and then they don't want to open
another trade
because whatever turns into a loss and then they're scared of losing money they
have.
And so their thought process is the opposite.
And again, that is psychological.
There's no amount of technical videos or indicators will solve that for you.
If you have psychological issues, you will need an inner edge, not just an
outer edge.
Again, we've had countless traders who have come to us that are part of
prosperity school,
for example, that have come to us that have edges that actually can trade.
They have technical edges.
They've showed me data.
Lewis, here's the data.
I have a strategy.
It works.
Here's the back testing results.
But for some reason, every time I trade it live, I'm not getting the same
results.
What is the issue?
Is the strategy wrong?
Am I trading it wrong?
Am I trading it different?
And it's like, yeah, you are trading it different, but not because of technical
.
You're trading it different because when you were back testing, you didn't have
fear.
You were just executing the edge as it should be executed.
But now all of a sudden in the live markets, when you're watching each one
minute candle
develop itself, you're getting into this mindset of, you're arguing with
yourself, you're
closing trades early, you're not taking trades when you should take trades, you
're avoiding
trades, you're hesitating and getting worse entries, you're like, there's so
many psychological
components that end up happening with people.
And they come to me and they're like, I'm in prosperity school, like, what
should I do?
Now, do you really think the solution for them is for me to give them another
trading
strategy?
Of course it's not.
They already know how to trade.
For them, they need to develop an inerage.
And so we help them develop an inerage, an operating system that transcends
technicals.
And they don't even need my training strategies.
They implement the inner edge, the imprint, an operating system.
And out of nowhere, they would have turned it around.
Now their ability to trade didn't change, their internal operating system
changed.
And again, that's why you can have, I can give you all these strategies for
free.
It doesn't mean you'll become profitable trader.
So hopefully if you're, you know, you have to have the self awareness, you have
to have
the level of self awareness that is able to identify what your actual issues
are, is your
issue technical?
Is it psychological?
Usually what happens is it starts out technical, because technical is first, it
doesn't matter
if you have this psychology of a monk and the discipline of a monk, if you don
't have
a technical edge, if you don't have the skill set to read price, if you don't
have a system,
no amount of meditation and self awareness and emotional intelligence is going
to save
you.
It's just not.
But what happens is when people develop the technical side of things, they
think they've
got it.
And that's when psychology comes, because again, psychology can only be an
issue after
you first have a profit glitch, because then it's about executing it.
And so yeah, most people when they get an edge, they think they've got it, and
then they
realize that they don't, but they don't have the self awareness to realize that
it's actually
psychological, not technical.
And so what do they do?
They ditch that trading strategy and they go and find a new one, they go find a
new indicator
or a new strategy, a new way of reading price, and they stay stuck here forever
.
And so I'm telling you this in hopes that someone, maybe one of you can see
that, ah,
maybe that resonates with me, and you're able to take the necessary steps in
your trading
career to work on yourself internally and build an in edge, not just an out
edge.
And so this is the perfect opportunity to get scale ins and not be fearful.
Because again, most people at this point, scared price coming back, brother
understand
that everything is in alignment for you, like you're on the right side of price
, or they
see this, right, price starts selling off and they're like, oh, missed it, just
missed
it.
Let me get in now.
And again, they do the same thing, right?
They might put their entry in here and their stop plus in here.
And then all of a sudden sweep and they're out, and then they're scared to rent
Reina.
And that's it done.
And again, for me, for the most part, five R is is enough.
And that's trade two, five R, trade one, five R, it's a total of 10 R.
Oh, really?
It's another thing as well, I think you look at all these people online.
I don't know.
I'm talking to you guys because maybe you've seen it a lot yourself.
These types of people that are doing this like $100 to $1,000,000 or $500 or $1
,000 to
$1,000,000.
Brother, is these your expectations or sister?
If these are your expectations, then yeah, you all learn the hard way.
That's not trading.
And those, that reality is heavily distorted, what's doable in the markets.
Now all of a sudden people look over 10% like it's nothing.
People don't understand what 10% can do for your life.
It's about capital and the management assets and the management.
If you have $300,000 in capital from prop firms, at 10% a month average, you're
making a life
change in money, but everyone wants to flip $1,000 to a million.
Not everyone, of course, maybe you're one of those people that do and yeah, I
have bad
news for you.
It's not happening, it doesn't happen, it's not real.
But yeah, that's the first trade that I wanted, the first two trades I wanted
to break down.
There's another one that I want to add to this and so I'll create a separate
video for
that one in just a moment.
But yeah, that's one of the most A+ setups that you can get, everything aligned
.
When everything's aligned, don't be afraid to double down because yeah, those
are the
witness.